welcome to the hubermann lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools for everyday
life
i'm andrew huberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology at
stanford school of medicine
this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science and science
related tools
to the general public in keeping with
that theme i'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is roca rocco makes
sunglasses
and eyeglasses and i'm delighted that
they're a partner
and a sponsor for the podcast as some of
you may already know
i've spent two decades or more studying
the visual system how we see
vision is absolutely the most important
sense by which humans navigate the world
and survive
and our eyes as two pieces of our brain
do many other important things as well
so taking good care of our eyesight is
essential founded by two all-american
swimmers from stamford
roca was born out of an obsession for
performance they carefully put science
and purpose behind their design choices
and they built absolutely terrific
products as a result
the glasses are amazing i love them
because they look great
they are super comfortable and the
optical clarity is
incredible they filter out sunlight in a
way that still allows you to see
contrast and shadows the way you need to
you know for me one of the things that's
really irritating is if i have a pair of
sunglasses
that don't allow me to see all the
things i want to see
and with roka glasses i get incredible
contrast but then i can also relax and
be outdoors in bright light and as the
amount of light changes with cloud cover
and things of that sort my ability to
see my surroundings
is still really sharp and really clear
and that only comes from really
understanding how the visual system
works
and how it adjusts to contrast and
adaptation and all these different
things they really
understand the science and that went
into the design of these glasses
and as many of you know sunlight and the
viewing of light is also very important
for setting circadian rhythms so that's
also been incorporated into the design
and science behind these glasses
i do wear readers i don't often wear
them during the podcast but i have to
wear reading glasses at night
so i use their readers and i own a pair
of their sunglasses and
i'm delighted with them if you'd like to
check out roka glasses you can go to
roca.com that's roka.com and enter the
code huberman
to save 20 off your first order that's
roka.com
enter the code huberman at checkout to
get 20 off your first order
today's podcast is also brought to you
by inside tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and dna
to help you better understand your body
and reach your health goals
i'm a big believer in getting regular
blood work done for the simple reason
that many of the important things that
are
vital to our immediate and long-term
health can only be detected in a good
quality blood test the problem with
blood tests is that
most blood tests you get a lot of
information back about levels that are
too high or too low of this thing or the
other thing
but making sense of that and what to do
with that information is very
challenging
even if you have a really attentive
physician oftentimes it's mysterious as
to what to do with all this data
with inside tracker they make it very
easy to understand what all the
metabolic factors hormone factors etc
mean for you and what to do about those
markers so they offer you directives in
terms of nutrition supplementation
as well as lifestyle factors like
exercise sleep etc
that can allow you to take control of
those numbers and bring them into the
ranges
that are best for you and your long-term
health another feature of inside tracker
that's great is their inner
age test this test shows you what your
biological age and how it compares to
your chronological age
which i can only imagine most everybody
including me are extremely interested in
how long am i likely to live how old am
i really
in terms of my biology if you'd like to
try inside tracker you can visit
insidetracker.com huberman to get 25
off any of inside tracker's plans use
the code huberman
at checkout today's episode is also
brought to us by athletic greens
athletic greens is an all-in-one vitamin
mineral probiotic drink
i've been using athletic green since
2012 and so i'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast
with athletic greens you get a ton of
factors that are good for you
mixed into this one really good tasting
drink i like to mix mine with water and
a little bit of lemon juice
and i drink that once or twice a day
typically once early in the day
and sometimes also in the afternoon or
even evening i'm able to sleep after
drinking in the evening just fine
the reason i've been using athletic
greens for so long that i continue to
use athletic greens
is that one i feel better when i take it
i just do
psychologically physically i feel better
but also it covers all my bases of the
things that i need
for my general health sort of a
foundational supplement as i like to
call it
in fact when people ask me what should i
take if i were to recommend just one
supplement that people
take it would be athletic greens with
athletic greens you get support for your
gut which is important because the gut
microbiome is important for the gut
brain access for mood metabolism
hormones etc there are so many
data that support that statement as well
there are many factors in athletic
greens that support general health
metabolism endocrine factors immunity
etc
so with athletic greens i drink it once
or twice a day and i know that i've got
all that covered
if you'd like to try athletic greens you
can go to athleticgreens.com
huberman and if you do that you can
claim a special offer they'll send you
five free travel packs plus a year surpr
supply excuse me of vitamin d3 and k2
so you get the 5 free travel packs and a
year supply of d3 if you go to
athleticgreens.com
huberman you can claim that special
offer for the last month
four episodes to be exact we've been
discussing
physical performance and skill learning
we've talked about how to learn skills
faster whether or not those are skills
for athletic performance
dance music things of that sort we've
also talked about how to gain strength
and how to lose fat faster by leveraging
the nervous system
things like shiver and non-shiver
non-exercise activity induced
thermogenesis we talked about how
neurons can actually
trigger accelerated fat loss we talked
about hypertrophy
also called muscle growth and we covered
everything from
sets and reps protocols how long to stay
in a cold ice bath when to get out
how to keep shivering we've covered a
lot of tools and a lot of science
so if you're interested in those things
and you even perhaps want to learn a
little bit
about how we make energy atp from
carbohydrates or from fats
it's all covered in the previous four
episodes this was going to be the time
that we moved to a new topic entirely
but we are going to do one more episode
in this series on physical performance
for the simple reason that you asked
many questions
about something that's vitally important
both for physical performance and
long-term
and short-term health and that's
endurance
and so today we are going to talk about
endurance now if you're a strength
athlete
or you're not interested in endurance
don't depart just yet because it turns
out that there are ways to train
endurance that are
very different than i would have
previously imagined
if you only think about long runs long
swims marathons half
marathons 10ks 5ks and that sort of
thing puts you to sleep kind of like
costello is snoring in the background
right now
he's not a long distance endurance
athlete that's for sure
if you're interested in those things or
if you are averse to those things
i encourage you to continue listening
because we are going to talk about
a little bit of science and then some
specific protocols that really define
what endurance is the four types of
endurance and ways to train those
in concert with the other things that
you might be doing like
weight training or skill training or
yoga
and if you are an endurance athlete we
are going to cover
a lot of tools and science that i'm
certain will also
help enhance your training and
performance in races or
even just recreationally the topic of
endurance
i think has been badly misrepresented
frankly online
and when you start digging into the
science and you start talking to
real experts in this area what you
discover what i've discovered is that
it's an incredibly
interesting area because it teaches us
so much about how our body and our brain
use fuels and how we can control which
fuels
are used by our body and brain so
today we will talk about the four kinds
of endurance we will also cover the
topic of hydration
which might sound incredibly boring like
okay just drink more water
but it's really interesting because not
only is hydration
a limiting factor on performance but
there is a right way
to hydrate and there is a wrong way to
hydrate there actually is a formula that
i'll teach you to know
how much water to be drinking depending
on your activity levels and
if that sounds like a simple thing like
oh just you know tap off water until
your
urine runs clear that's actually the
wrong advice
it turns out that if you don't hydrate
properly you can see 20 to 30 percent
reductions in performance whether or not
that strength
whether that's increasing hypertrophy
whether or not that's running
swimming even mental performance so even
if you're not an athlete or a
recreational athlete at all
i encourage you to stay tuned for the
part about hydration
so we're going to cover as usual a
little bit of science and then we're
going to dive right into protocols
that you can apply if you like and if
you deem those correct and safe
for you before we dive into all that i
want to make an important announcement
which is
all the episodes of the hubermann lab
podcast are now housed on a single
website
which is hubermanlab.com if you go to
hubermannlab.com you can find all the
episodes
in youtube apple and spotify format with
links there
the website is also searchable so if you
go into the little search function which
you'll find very easily and you put in
for instance
creatine or sleep or ice bath
or sauna it will take you to the
specific episodes
that contain that information and in
addition
if you go to the website hubermanlab.com
you have the opportunity
to sign up for what we call the
hubermann lab neural network
the hubermann lab neural network is a
zero cost resource
where once a month perhaps more often
you'll receive
a email newsletter and that newsletter
will contain
specific protocols announcements
attachments of pdfs and things of that
sort
of protocols tools and science from the
podcast
we will also make any announcements
about
live lectures which at some point i'll
probably start doing in various cities
in the us and probably around the world
as well as well as
other things that i think would be
really useful to you all of course
at zero cost so that's hubermanlab.com
sign up for the neural network
newsletter you can find that in the menu
tab or it might pop
up when you get there and i hope you
will join and
as a final announcement if you're not
already following us on instagram
you can go to huberman lab on instagram
and if you do that i often make
announcements and release protocols and
links to protocols and things there
as well i briefly want to touch on
something from the previous episode
which is that if you are somebody that
is trying to increase
muscle strength and or size or if you're
simply somebody
who doesn't want to increase muscle
strength and size
you just want to maintain the
musculature that you have
it's vital that you perform at least
five sets of resistance training per
muscle
per week if we don't do that we lose
muscle over time
and that is one reason among many
to have a regular resistance training
protocol
nobody wants to start resembling a
folded over envelope or a melted candle
no one wants to have challenges getting
up out of a chair or off the ground
maintaining musculature is vital not
just to our immediate health but to our
long-term health trajectory
so i just want to emphasize that point
if you're curious about the sets the
reps
how close to failure to go or not go
whether or not you should be
doing your cardiovascular training
before or after your weight training all
of that is in the previous episode
right down to the details and i like to
think made simple
for you to understand but i do strongly
believe that resistance training whether
or not it's with body weight or bands
or weights or simply lifting rocks in
the yard or logs in the yard
is vital for our systemic physiology and
our overall health and that includes our
brain health
and i described the reasons for that and
the mechanisms in the previous episode
today i'd like to talk about endurance
and how to build
endurance and how to use endurance
for the health of your entire body
endurance as the name suggests is our
ability to engage in continuous
bouts of exercise or continuous movement
or continuous effort of any kind
and i do believe that our ability to
engage in
activities that we call endurance
training or physical endurance
activities
do have carryover to
mental performance of things that
require long-term
effort i'll touch on that at the end and
why
there's reason to believe that there's a
biological crossover between those two
things
i don't think it's simply the case that
if you train yourself to be a strength
and speed athlete and to do short bouts
of exercise that are very intense
that you can only do mental work that's
of short bouts and very intense
but it is clear that cardiovascular
exercise
exercise where you're getting your heart
rate up continuously for a period of
time and endurance
exercise we will define what that is in
a moment is vital
for tapping into and enhancing various
aspects
of our biology in the body and in the
brain
such that our brain can perform work
for longer periods of time focused work
learning etc
so i want to dive into the topic of
endurance and i want to just
begin by addressing something that's
vital to any kind of effort whether or
not it's mental effort or physical
effort so as always a little bit of
science and we'll get right into
protocols
so the key thing to understand about
energy production in the body
meaning your ability to think your
ability to talk your ability to walk
your ability to run
is this thing that we call atp atp
and mitochondria which are just
little what we call organelles within
cells these are little
factories that make energy if you will
atp is required for anything that
requires
energy for anything that you do that
requires effort
and there are different ways to get
atp and we have been gifted
as a species with the ability to convert
lots of things into atp
we can convert carbohydrates literally
the kinds of carbohydrates you eat a
bagel you eat a piece of pizza
pizza usually is dough and it has cheese
and some other things
costello here as we talk about pizza
custard loves pizza by the way
eating a piece of pizza it gets
converted into various things
fatty acids from the fats glucose
from the bread and those
things get converted into atp within
cells
through things like glycolysis things
like lipolysis i talked about this in
previous episodes
so our muscles and our neurons
use different fuel sources to generate
atp
the ones that are used first for short
bouts of intense activity are things
like phosphocreatine if you've only
heard about creatine as a supplement
well phosphocreatine actually exists in
our muscles
and that's why people take creatine you
can load your muscles with more creatine
and though and excuse me phosphate
creatine
is great for short intense bouts of
effort
so when you're really pushing hard on
something physical let's say you see a
car on the side of the road
and that car is stalled and a person
says hey can you help me push my car and
you start to push
that's gonna be phosphocreatine it's
gonna be your main fuel source
then you start to tap into things like
glucose which is literally just
carbohydrate it's just sugar that's in
your blood
and then if you keep pushing on that car
you keep in
engaging in a particular effort or you
keep studying or you keep listening to
this podcast
you start to tap into other fuel sources
like glycogen from your liver which is
just
it's like a little pack just like you
know you might have packed a sandwich or
something for work
you have a little pack of glycogen in
your liver that you can rely on
and you have fat stored in adipose
tissue even if you have
very very low body fat percentage like
you're one of these
people as like three percent or five
percent body fat really
thin skin very little body fat
you can extract lipids fatty acids from
that body fat it's like a storage pack
it is a storage pack for energy that can
be converted to atp
so without going into any more detail
when i say today energy or i say atp
just remember
that regardless of your diet regardless
of
your nutritional plan your body has the
capacity
to use creatine glucose glycogen lipids
and if you're ketogenic ketones we'll
talk about ketosis
in order to generate fuel energy
now the other crucial point is that in
order to
complete that process of taking these
fuels and converting them into energy
most of the time you need oxygen
you need air basically in your system
now it's not actual air you need oxygen
molecules in your system
comes in through your mouth and your
nose goes to your lungs and distributes
via the bloodstream oxygen is not a fuel
but like a fire that has no oxygen
you can't actually burn the logs but
when you blow a lot of
oxygen onto a fire basically
onto a logs with a flame there then
basically it will take five
it will take fire it will burn okay
oxygen
allows you to burn fuel so today we are
going to ask the critical questions
what allows us to perform what allows us
to continue effort for long periods of
time and that effort could be a run it
could be a swim
it could be studying it could be
anything that
extends over a long period of time well
you're going to need energy and you're
going to need oxygen
but the way to answer a question like
what allows us to endure right endurance
what allows us to keep going well
we think of things like willpower but
what's willpower willpower
is neurons it's neurons in our brain we
have this thing called the central
governor which decides whether or not we
should or could continue or whether or
not we should
stop whether or not we should quit okay
so whether or not you're somebody who
has a lot of what we would call
resilience and endurance or whether or
not you're somebody who
taps out early and quits early or can't
handle frustration that has to do with
your fuel utilization in specific
neurons
so we have to ask the question what is
the limiting
factor on performance right so instead
of saying what allows us to endure
we should say what prevents us from
enduring what prevents us from moving
forward what are the factors
that say you know what no more i'm not
going to continue this run or
you know what i've had a really long
hard day or maybe i've had an easy day
or i'm feeling lazy i just don't even
really feel like getting up and moving
so what we're going to talk about today
actually gets right down to the heart of
motivation
and fuel use motivation and fuel
allocation
and we are going to talk about specific
training protocols that you can
follow that have carryover between the
bodily systems of running swimming etc
and the way that your brain works so
let's talk about endurance by asking
first what
are the limiting factors on endurance
what stops us
because in addressing that and answering
that we will understand
what allows us to get into effort and to
continue effort
there are five main categories of things
that allow us to engage in effort
and they are neurons nerves
muscle muscle blood
things in our blood our heart
and our lungs now i don't want to
completely write off things like the
immune system
and other systems of the body but nerve
muscle blood heart
and lungs are the five that i want to
focus on today because
that's where most of the data are as we
go forward into this i want to
acknowledge
dr andy galpin who as with the last
episode it's been tremendously helpful
and informative in terms of the exercise
physiology is a
true expert he has a laboratory he's a
full professor
who does work on muscle biopsy who
understands the science but who also
works with athletes and works with
recreational athletes professional
athletes
really understands at a variety of
levels how all these systems work he's
the person i consulted with about
today's episode although i did access
other literature as well and i'm going
to mention
a key review for any of you aficionados
who really want to get down into the
weeds
but i encourage you if you want more
detail to check out
dr andy galpin's youtube page i think
he's also on twitter he's definitely on
instagram
his content is excellent and he really
understands i
have learned and i really believe that
an intellectual
is somebody who understands a topic at
multiple levels
of specificity of detail and can
communicate that and
andy is a true intellectual of muscle
physiology and performance
and if you hear the word intellectual
and you kind of back up and cringe from
that
understand that he's also a practitioner
so thank you andrew galpin
andy galpin for
your support in these episodes and we
hope to have you as a guest on the
podcast
soon so nerve muscle blood heart and
lungs let's talk about neurons and how
they work
okay but i want to tell you about an
experiment that's going to make
it very clear why quitting
is a mental thing not a physical thing
so why do we quit
well an experiment was done a couple
years ago and was published in the
journal cell
cell press journal excellent journal
showing that there
is a class of neurons in our brain stem
in the back of our brain
that if they shut off
we quit now these neurons
release epinephrine epinephrine is
adrenaline and any time we are engaged
in effort of any kind
we are releasing epinephrine any time
we're awake really we are releasing
epinephrine
into our brain in fact
this little group of neurons in the back
of our brain is called the locus
ceruleus if you like
is churning out epinephrine all the time
but if something stresses us out
it turns out more and then it acts as
kind of an alertness signal for the
whole brain
we also of course have adrenaline
epinephrine released in our body which
makes our body
ready for things so think about
epinephrine as a readiness signal
and when we are engaged in effort this
readiness signal is being churned into
our brain when we're relaxed and we're
falling asleep
epinephrine levels are low okay
so they did a really interesting
experiment
where they had subjects engage in bouts
of
effort of trying to move forward toward
a goal
but they manipulated the visual
environment with these stripes kind of
like fences passing on both sides of
them
and by doing that they could trick
subjects
into thinking that their effort was
either allowing them to move forward
right because these rungs on the fence
were moving
past or that their effort was futile
that they were no longer moving forward
because they would make the rungs move
slowly even though
the subjects were making a lot of effort
to move forward okay
so this is analogous or similar to being
on a treadmill and you're trying to walk
on this treadmill
and you just can't move the conveyor
right or you're in virtual reality and
you're
putting a ton of effort but it seems
like you're moving excruciatingly slow i
had this experience recently in real
life
i was doing a swim in the pacific i was
trying to go
south and i was swimming and i was
caught in a current not the kind that
pulls you out to ocean and i kept
looking to my left
and i saw this hotel on the shoreline
and then i was
swimming and swimming and swimming and
swimming and 20 minutes later i looked
to my left and the hotel is still
exactly where it was before which meant
that i wasn't moving
it felt futile eventually
either the current changed or something
change and i eventually
swam past the hotel got back on the
beach and eventually
drove home that's essentially what they
did in this experiment but what they
found was
these neurons that release epinephrine
there's another cell type called glia
which actually means glue in latin
that is paying attention to how much
epinephrine is being released and at
some point
the system reaches a threshold it
reaches this threshold and it shuts off
the release of more epinephrine it's
like i quit that's it
no more effort signal if they could
extend
the time before those glia said ah
enough
if they could release more adrenaline
into the system then
subjects would keep going so our
desire to continue or put differently
our willingness to continue and our
desire to quit
is mediated by events between our two
ears
now that doesn't mean that the body's
not involved but it means that neurons
are critically important so we have two
categories of neurons that are important
the ones in our head that tell us get up
and go out and take that run
and the ones that allow us encourage us
to continue that run
and we have neurons that shut things off
that say no more
and we of course have the neurons that
connect to our muscles and control our
muscles
but the reason we quit is rarely because
our body quits
our mind quits now we never want to
encourage people to
drive themselves to the point of injury
that's not
going to be good for anybody but
it is good to know that it's neural our
ability to persist is neural so when
people say
is it i hear that you know sports or
effort or
fighting or um it's 90 mental
10 physical you know that that whole
discussion about how much is mental how
much is physical is
absolutely silly it just proves that
there's no knowledge of the underlying
biology
behind that statement it's neither
mental nor physical
everything is physical everything is
neurons
your thinking is the responsibility of
chemicals and electrical signals in your
head
so it's not 90 percent mental 10
physical it's not
50 50. it's not 70 30. it's
100 nervous system it's neurons
okay so when people say mental or
physical understand it's
100 neural and i'd love for the
how much of of it is mental and how much
is physical to just disappear
that that argument means nothing and
it's not actionable
now what do nerves need in order to
continue to fire what do you need in
order to get neurons to say
i will persist well they need glucose
unless you're keto and ketogenic adapted
you need carbohydrate is glucose that's
what neurons
run on and you need electrolytes
neurons have what's called a sodium
potassium pump blah blah blah they
generate electricity
we could go into all this i will
probably do an entire lecture about the
action potential but basically
in order to get nerves nerve cells to
fire to contract muscle
to say i'm going to continue you need
sufficient sodium
salt because the action potential the
actual firing of neurons
is driven by sodium entering the cell
rushing into the cell
and then there's a removal of potassium
and then there's a kind of resetting of
those levels
by something called the sodium potassium
pump and the sodium potassium pump and
sodium and action potentials
even if you don't know anything about
that is atp
dependent it requires energy so you need
energy in order to get neurons to fire
and it is ph dependent it depends on
the conditions or the environment within
the brain being of a certain ph
or acidity ph is about how acid or how
basic the environment is and we will
talk a little bit about ph in simple
terms that you can understand so nerves
need salt they need potassium
and it turns out they need magnesium and
you need glucose and carbohydrates in
order to power those neurons unless
you are running on ketones and to run on
ketones you have to make sure that
you're
fully keto adapted i will talk about
adding in ketones
on top of carbohydrate at the end of the
episode
okay so that's how nerves work you need
carbohydrate you need sodium potassium
and magnesium in order to
drive the brain muscle
muscle is going to engage and generate
energy first by using this
phospho-creatine system
high bouts of effort really intense
effort short-lived
seconds to minutes but probably more
like seconds this could be this
phosphate creatine literally a fuel
source in the muscle that you're going
to burn
just like you would logs on a fire
and glycogen which is stored
carbohydrate in the muscle
that also can be burned just like logs
on a fire to generate energy so
let me make this crystal clear if you
move your wrist towards your shoulder
and contract your bicep really hard
muscle fibers are burning up their own
carbohydrate they're converting that
into atp in order to generate that
energy
okay and ph is important
and temperature is important
in the episode on supercharge your
physical performance i talked all about
how
by using cooling specifically of the
palms or the bottoms of the feet or the
cheeks of the face
using particular methods you can adjust
the temperature
of the body and of muscle in a way that
allows you to do more work to do more
reps
to run further to keep going and to
persist
and that's because if temperature is too
low
or too high then atp
is not going to be available because of
this whole thing called the pyruvate
kinase
pathway and the temperature dependence
of pyruvate kinase check out that
episode if you want to learn more about
that but temperature
is important and ph is also important so
we got nerve muscle
and then there's stuff in our blood
that's available as an energy source
and in blood we've got glucose so
literally blood sugar that's floating
around so let's say you
have fasted for three days your blood
glucose is going to be very low
so that's not going to be a great fuel
source but you will start to liberate
fats from your adipose tissue from your
fat
fatty acids will start to mobilize into
the bloodstream and you can burn
those for energy and oxygen in your
blood when you inhale
you're bringing oxygen into your blood
so these are all fuel sources in your
neurons in your muscle
in your blood in your various tissues
that are
providing the opportunity to
give effort to to induce effort whether
or not to run or swim or writing or
talking
now there are some other factors that
are important
and those are the heart which is going
to move blood
so the more that the heart can move
blood and oxygen
well the more fuel that's going to be
available
for you to engage in muscular effort and
thinking effort so your heart is vitally
important to your
your muscles ability to work in your
brain's ability to work
and as i've mentioned oxygen a few times
it should be obvious then that the lungs
are very important you need to bring
oxygen in and distribute it to all these
tissues
because oxygen is critical for the
conversion of carbohydrates
and the conversion of fats and
we could get into the discussion about
whether or not oxygen is important for
ketogenic metabolism but you need oxygen
there you need to breathe and you need
to breathe properly
so i just covered what would normally be
about
four lectures of energy consumption and
energy utilization i didn't go into much
detail at all but
what i want you to imagine is that
you've got these different cell types
you've got neurons you've got
muscle they need to collaborate in order
to generate
effort or to make the decision to do
something or to think hard or to run
hard or to run far and then you've got
fuel sources both
in the neurons in the muscle
in your blood and then the heart and
lungs are
are going to help distribute the oxygen
and those fuels
and of course you have that little
energy pack that we call the liver
that will allow you to pull out a little
more carbohydrate if you need it for
work okay so that's as much as i want to
cover about energy consumption
because that's a lot but what it tells
you is that when you eat and you use
food as a fuel source that food can be
broken down and you can immediately burn
the glucose that's in your bloodstream
or you can rely on some of the stored
fuel in your liver
or you can rely on stored fuel in the
muscle so called glycogen
and there are a lot of different ways
that we can generate atp
so when we ask the question what's
limiting for performance
what is going to allow us to endure to
engage in effort and endure
long balance of effort or even
moderately long balance of effort
we need to ask which of those things
nerve muscle blood
heart and lungs is limiting or
put differently we ask what should we be
doing with our neurons what should we be
doing with our muscles what should we be
doing with our blood
what should we be doing with our heart
and what should we be doing with our
lungs
that's going to allow us to build
endurance
for mental and physical work and to be
able to go
longer further with more intensity
that's the real question how can we do
more work
and the way we do that is with energy
and the way to get energy to it is by
those five things
and so now we're going to talk about how
you can actually
build different types of endurance and
what that
does at the level of your blood your
heart your muscles and your neurons so
we're going to skip
back and forth between protocols tools
and the underlying science so rather
than heavy stack the science at the
front end and then just give you all the
tools at the end
we're going to talk about the protocols
the four kinds of endurance and how to
achieve them and we are going to talk
about the underlying science as we move
through that
if you would like a lot of detailed
science i encourage you to check out a
review
that we've linked in the show notes and
the review is called
adaptations to endurance and strength
training this is a
review article with many excellent
citations it's from cold spring harbor
perspectives in medicine the cold spring
harbor press is an
excellent scientific press it's been the
last 21 years doing
summers at cold spring harbor teaching
neuroscience but
cold spring harbor is involved in all
sorts of themes and topics
related to neuroscience and medicine
this review
by hughes elephant
elephant that's the name alphasyn and
bar b-a-a-r
adaptations to endurance and strength
training is rich with citations
it can be downloaded as a complete pdf
there's no paywall
and we will link to it and it gets
really deep
into all the signaling cascades the
genetic changes within muscle
with high intensity interval training
short term super high intensity training
uh weight training so if you're a real
nerd for this stuff and you want to get
right down into how pgc one alpha p53
and ph
20 change the adaptation features of
muscle and gene regulation that is
definitely the review for you
if you're like most people and you're
not really interested in that level of
detail
no reason to pick up the review unless
you just want to check out some of the
the figures and pictures
but i do want to offer that as a
resource it's been a
in addition to discussions with dr andy
galpin it's been a
primary resource for the content of this
episode
so let's talk about the four kinds of
endurance and how to achieve those
i do believe that everybody should have
some sort of
endurance practice regular endurance
practice
it's clear that it's vital for the
functioning of the body and the mind
and there are clear longevity benefits
there are a lot of reasons why that's
true but
the main one is that if we have
good energy utilization in our
musculature
and in our blood in our vascular system
and
in our oxygenating system our lungs the
so-called cardiovascular system
respiratory system and musculature the
body and brain
function much better there are so many
papers now
so much data to support that so i do
believe everyone should
either try to maintain the muscle that
they have provided they've already gone
through puberty and development
and they should be engaged in regular
endurance exercise
now for many people they think endurance
exercise that means what
an hour long run or i got to get on the
stairmaster or i have to treadmill for
hours on end each week
it turns out that's not the case there
are four kinds of endurance and you can
train specifically for any one of those
and you can vary your training so let's
talk about those four kinds of endurance
these are very interesting and they each
have very different
protocols that you use in order to build
and maximize them and now you'll
understand
what fuel sources they use in order to
build that thing we call endurance so
first of all
we have muscular endurance muscular
endurance
is the ability for our muscles
to perform work over time
and our failure to continue
to be able to perform that work is going
to be due to
muscular fatigue not to cardiovascular
fatigue so not because we're breathing
too hard or we can't get enough blood to
the muscles
or because we quit mentally but because
the muscles themselves
give out okay one good example of this
would be if you had to pick up
a stone in the yard and that stone
is not extremely heavy for you and you
needed to do that anywhere from 50 to
100 times
and you you're picking it up and putting
it down and picking it up and putting it
down and picking up and putting it down
at some point your muscles will fatigue
they will
fail to endure muscular endurance is
incredibly useful
for a variety of physical pursuits
and we'll talk about the mental pursuits
that it supports as well
in terms of physical pursuits the
ability for a given muscle to perform
repeated work is going to improve your
golf swing it's going to improve
your tennis swing it's going to improve
your posture your ability to
dance your ability to repeatedly engage
in an activity that requires effort
in a way that's very different from the
kind of endurance that you will build
simply by increasing your cardiovascular
fitness your ability to generate kind of
easy repetition so let's talk about
muscular endurance and what it is
muscular endurance is going to be
something that you
can perform for anywhere from 12
to 25 or even up to 100 repetitions
and that's actually how if you like you
would train muscular endurance
and i'll give this specific protocol in
a few moments
so a good example is push-ups right if
you were to
get on the floor and start doing
push-ups
even if you're somebody who has to do
knees down push-ups
and you're doing your push-ups
eventually you won't be able to do any
more push-ups and that's not going to be
because
you couldn't get enough oxygen into your
system
or your heart wasn't pumping enough
blood it's going to be because the
muscles
fail that's why so if you want to be
able to do more push-ups
or even more pull-ups muscular endurance
is really what it's about
it's actually no coincidence that a lot
of military boot camp style training
is not done with weights it's done with
things like push-ups pull-ups
sit-ups and running because what they're
really building is muscular endurance
the ability to perform work repeatedly
over time
for a given set of muscles and neurons
so what's a good protocol to build
muscular endurance let's just give that
to you now and explain
some of the underlying science as that
as it follows
so a really good muscular endurance
training protocol
according to the scientific literature
would be three to five sets of anywhere
from
12 to 100 repetitions that's a huge
range
now 12 to 25 repetitions is going to be
more reasonable for most people
and the rest periods are going to be
anywhere from 30 to 180 seconds
of rest so anywhere from half a minute
to three minutes of rest so this might
be
five sets of push-ups done getting your
maximum push-up so for some people that
might be zero and you have to do it
knees down
for some people it might be ten push-ups
for some people might be 25 but you
could go all the way up to 100
rest anywhere from 30 to 180 seconds and
then
do your next set for a total of three to
five sets so it doesn't actually sound
like a ton of work
the other thing you could do is
something like a plank a plank position
is actually a way to build muscular
endurance
not strength okay it's i'm sure it could
be used to develop strength
but it's really about muscular endurance
so you would do three to five sets of
planks those planks
would probably even because you're not
doing repetitions it's an isometric hold
as we say it's kind of static hold
or a wall sit would be another example
and you would do that
probably for a minute or two minutes
take some rest of anywhere from 30 or 60
or 180 seconds and then repeat so things
like pushing a sled
push-ups isometric planks even pull-ups
those will all work and
as with other forms of training you
would want to do this until you approach
failure or actually fail and where
you're unable to perform another
repetition that would mark the end of a
set
the one critical feature of building
muscular endurance
is that it has no major eccentric
loading component now i haven't talked
much about eccentric and concentric
loading
but concentric loading is when you are
shortening
the muscle typically or lifting a weight
and eccentric movements are when you are
lengthening a muscle
typically or lowering a weight so if you
do a pull
up and you get your chin over the bar or
chin up
that's the concentric portion of the
effort and then as you lower yourself
that's the eccentric
portion eccentric portion of
resistance training of any kind whether
or not it's for endurance or for
strength
is one of the major causes of soreness
some people will be more susceptible
to of this to this excuse me than others
but it does create more damage in muscle
fibers
muscular endurance and building muscular
endurance should not include
any movements that include major
eccentric loads so if you're going to do
push-ups it doesn't mean that you want
to drop you know smash your chest into
the floor
and by the way your chest should touch
the ground on every push-up that's a
real push-up
okay it's not about breaking 90 with the
elbows it's about
pushing down until your chest touch the
floor and straightening out that's a
proper push-up
and a pull-up is where you pull your
chin above the bar
neither of those should include a slow
eccentric or lowering component
if you are using those to train muscular
endurance the three to five sets of 12
to 25 and maybe even up to 100
repetitions with
30 to 180 seconds of rest in between
that means that jumping also is going to
be a very
poor tool for building muscular
endurance
because jumping has a slowing down
component as you land
so things like plyometrics or agility
work where you're moving from side to
side and you're decelerating you're
slowing yourself down a lot
not going to be good for muscular
endurance terrific for cardiovascular
training and conditioning of other kinds
and skill training and agility and all
that
but if you want to build muscular
endurance you want to make your muscles
able to do more work for longer
it's going to be this three to five sets
of 12 to 100 reps
30 to 180 seconds of mainly concentric
movement okay not a
slow lowering phase or a heavy lowering
phase
so that might be kettlebell swings and
things of that sort
isometrics as i mentioned things like
plank wall sets will work
now what's interesting about this is
that it doesn't seem at
all like what people normally think of
as endurance
and yet it's been shown in nice quality
peer-reviewed studies
several of which are cited in the review
i mentioned earlier
that muscular endurance can improve
our ability to engage in long bouts of
what we call
long duration low intensity endurance
work so this can support
long runs it can support long swims and
it can build
also it can build postural
strength and endurance simultaneously
and that's mainly accomplished through
isometric hold so things like
planks are actually quite good for
building endurance of the spinal erector
muscles that provide
posture of the abdominal muscles that
are helpful for posture for being
upright
for the upper neck muscles and things of
that sort we
these days everyone seems to have text
neck everyone's basically staring at
their toes all the time it has a default
towards their toes
so isometric holds can be very good for
building muscular endurance
you can spot people including yourself
perhaps with poor muscular endurance in
the postural muscles because anytime
they stop moving they have to lean
against a wall
or their hip will move to one side or
they're always lean to one side
i am guilty of this too some of you have
actually pointed out i like to think out
of concern
that i often am rubbing my lower back
and indeed i have some asymmetries in my
postural
muscles some of which are probably
genetic and some of which are probably
just from
excessive work or something of that sort
that have my right shoulder sit lower
than my left and things that sort
if i wanted to improve those i could
improve those by really focusing on
symmetry
and isometric symmetry meaning hold my
holding my hands at equivalent positions
in planks
and doing isometric holds for building
muscular endurance of the postural
muscles
but this can also be done with as i
mentioned kettlebell swings for the
lower back and legs and
posterior chains so there are a number
of different exercises you could do this
with but
it should be compound exercises mainly
it's rare for people to do
this kind of muscular endurance work
specifically for things like
bicep curls or triceps and there aren't
many activities that really rely on
isolation of those muscles and
repeatedly
right it's hard i'm sure there are some
out there but it's kind of hard to
imagine
so you can do this with isometrics you
can do this with
more standard non-isometric type
movements but make sure there isn't a
strong eccentric load so now let's talk
about the science briefly of
why this works well that takes us back
to this issue of fuel utilization and
what
fails so if we were to say okay uh let's
say you do a plank
uh and you're planking for you know
maybe you're able to plank for a minute
or two minutes or three minutes
at some point you will fail you're not
going to fail because the heart gives
out
you're not going to fail because you
can't get enough oxygen because you can
breathe while you're doing that
you're going to fail because of local
muscular failure which means that as you
do
if you choose to do this protocol of
three to five sets etc etc
to build muscular endurance mainly what
you are
going to be building is you're going to
be building
the ability of your mitochondria to use
oxygen to generate energy locally and
that it's something called mitochondrial
respiration
respiration because of the the
involvement of oxygen
and it's also going to be
increasing the extent to which the
neurons
control the muscles and provide a
stimulus for the muscles to contract
but this is independent of power and
strength okay so even though the
the low sets like three to five sets and
the fact that you're doing repetitions
and you're going to failure even though
it seems to resemble
power and strength and hypertrophy type
training it is distinctly different it's
not going to generate strength
hypertrophy and power
it's going to mainly create this ability
to endure to continually contract
muscles or repeatedly contract muscles
okay continually if you're using
isometric holds repeatedly
repeatedly excuse me if you're using
repetition type
exercise where there's a contraction
and an extension of the muscle
essentially a concentric and an
eccentric
portion but remember that you want the
eccentric portion to be
light and relatively fast not so fast
that you injure yourself but certainly
not
deliberately slowed down it was
recommended i should say by andy galpin
that
you not use olympic lifts for this
because once you get past 8 or 12 or 25
repetitions
especially form on those olympic lifts
is key for not getting
injured and while some people can
perform those sorts of
of lifts like you know snatches and
deadlifts and cleans and jerks and
overhead presses
probably not a great idea if
the goal is to push the body to points
of fatigue because you do open yourself
up to injury unless you're very skilled
at doing that or you have a really good
coach who can help you guide
through those lifts so that's one form
of endurance which is muscular endurance
that's mainly going to rely
on neural energy so nerves
and muscle and it's not going to rely
quite so much on what's available in
your blood your heart or your lungs
so now let's talk about the other
extreme of endurance
which is long duration endurance this is
the type that people typically think
about
when they think about endurance you're
talking about a long run
a long swim a long bike ride well how
long
will anywhere from 12 minutes to
several hours or maybe even an entire
day maybe eight or nine hours
of hiking or running or biking some
people are actually doing those kinds of
really long events marathons for
instance
so anything longer than 12 minutes and
this type of work builds on fuel
utilization
in the muscles it builds on
the activity of neurons in the brain
that are involved in what we call
central pattern
generators we talked about this in a
previous episode or
several previous episodes these are
groups of neurons that allow our body to
engage in
regular rhythmic effort without having
to think about the movement too much
so running and stepping or swimming if
you already know how to swim or pedaling
on a bike
or walking upstairs and hiking you're
not thinking about right left right left
it's all carried out by central pattern
generators
this is going to be at less than 100
percent
of your maximum oxygen uptake your vo2
max i'll talk about what vo2 max is
but i just want to give a sense of what
the protocol is and the underlying
science
how many sets one long duration
effort is one set of 12 minutes or
longer
so you're not counting repetitions i
sure hope that if you're going out on a
30 minute run or even a 15 minute run
that you're not
counting steps that you're not counting
pedal strokes that you're not
on the row or counting pulls on the
rower
i suppose you could but i think that
would be pretty dreadful
seems like a poor utilization of
cognitive brain space
you're getting into regular repeated
effort
and your ability to continue that effort
is going to be dependent mainly on the
efficiency of the movement
on your ability to strike a balance
between
the the movement itself the generation
of the muscular movements
that are required and fuel utilization
across the different sources of nerve
muscle blood heart and lungs so let's
ask the question
why would you fail on a long run why
would you quit
well as you set out on that long run
assuming you have some glycogen in your
liver and in your muscles you're going
to use that energy first
even if it's very low intensity okay so
we're not talking about sprinting we're
talking about
heading out the door or starting off on
a marathon
you're starting to assuming you have
some conditioning or even if you don't
you're going to burn carbohydrate you're
going to burn glucose in the bloodstream
you're going to burn carbohydrate as
those muscles contract those what we
call slow twitch muscles they're
contracting they start burning up fuel
to make atp to continue to contract
your mind is going to use more
or less energy depending on how much
will power how much of a fight you have
to get into with yourself in order to
generate the effort
i really want to underscore this if
you're somebody that's thinking maybe i
go for the run maybe i don't go for the
run i'll do it at two o'clock okay 205
no i only want to go on the half hour or
maybe on the main hour
and you're going through all that guess
what you're burning up useful energy
that you could use either for the run
for example
or for something else when we think
about something hard when we ruminate
when we per perseverate on on an idea or
on a decision
we are burning neural energy and neural
energy is glucose
and epinephrine and all the things we
talked about before
so willpower in part is the ability
to devote resources to things and part
of that
is making decisions to just either do it
or not do it i'm not of the just do it
mindset i think there's a right time and
a place to train but i also think that
it is not good in other words it
utilizes
excessive resources to churn over
decisions
excessively and you probably burn
as much cognitive energy deciding about
whether or not to do a given
training or not as you do in the actual
training
okay so we'll talk more about how this
long-duration effort can relate to
mental performance but
the long-duration effort should be one
set 12 minutes or longer
it could go for 30 minutes or 60 minutes
or an hour we'll talk about programming
later in the episode this is going to be
less than 100 of your maximum
oxygen uptake your heart rate is not
going to be through the ceiling or maxed
out
but it's all about efficiency of
movement that's what you're building
when you go out for a run that's 30
minutes you are building the capacity
to repeat that performance the next time
while being more efficient actually
burning less
fuel and that might seem a little bit
counterintuitive but every time you do
that
run what you're doing is you're building
up mitochondrial density
it's not so much about mitochondrial
oxidation
and respiration you're building up
mitochondrial density you're actually
increasing the amount of atp that you
can create
for a given bout of effort you're
becoming more
efficient okay you're burning less fuel
overall
doing the same thing that's really what
these long slow distance or long ballots
of effort are really all about
now why do this long duration effort why
would you want to do it why is it good
for you well
it does something very important which
is that it
builds the capillary beds within muscles
so let's talk a little bit about
vasculature we haven't done this too
much
yet but if you have seen the episode on
supercharging performance we talked
about
avas these arteriovenous astomosis
where blood moves from arteries
directly into veins but that's unusual
that only takes place
in the so-called glabrous skin of the
of the palms the face and the bottoms of
the feet typically
for most all other areas of the body
what happens is
arteries bring blood to a given tissue
like a muscle
and veins return that blood back to the
heart
there are exceptions but in general and
in between arteries and veins are these
little tiny
what are called capillary beds or
microcapillaries so these are tiny
little avenues like little tiny streams
and estuaries
between the bigger arteries and veins
now
those are actually contained within
muscle
and what's amazing is that you can
increase the number of them
you can literally build new capillaries
you can create
new little streams within your muscles
and the type of long duration
effort that i was talking about before
12 minutes or more of
steady effort is very useful for doing
that
and is very useful in for increasing the
mitochondria
the energy producing elements of the
cells the actual muscle cells
and the reason is when
blood arrives to muscles it has oxygen
the muscles are going to use some of
that oxygen and then some of the
deoxygenated blood is going to be sent
back to the heart and to the lungs now
the more capillaries that you
build into those muscles the more oxygen
available to those muscles i don't want
to get too much into the physics of
fluid flow
but basically it's the difference
between taking a hose and sticking it
into some dirt
um just directly like and turning on the
faucet at a given rate
uh the spigot rather or having a bunch
of little hoses like a sprinkler system
that go out and
irrigate the whole yard the irrigation
is equivalent to this capillary bed
system
and it's very good at using
energy sources within blood so the
simple way to think about this
is when you go out for a run let's say
it's the first run you've done for a
while and you go out for 12 or 15
minutes and somewhere right around
20 minutes you're like that's it i just
can't continue well when you come back
the next time to do that run
you've built endurance largely because
you've built these capillary beds you've
expanded these little streams in which
blood can deliver oxygen to the muscles
and so it's going to feel relatively
straightforward to either go a little
bit quicker for the same duration
the same distance or to extend that run
for another five to ten minutes
so this long duration work unlike
muscular endurance like planks and
everything that we were talking about
before
is really about building the capillary
systems and the mitochondria
the energy utilization systems within
the muscles
themselves and that's very important to
understand
it's distinctly different than say
building the neurons that fire the
muscles the neurons are already there
they're going to fire those muscles just
fine
in fact if your life depended on it
today you could probably run a marathon
you'd probably get injured it would be
very psychologically and physically
painful i don't recommend you do that
unless you're trained for it
but if you were to train properly for it
if you were to do long duration bouts of
effort
once or twice a week or three times a
week pretty soon it would become easy
because you're
building these vascular micro beds or
microvascular beds as they're called
okay so you're able to bring more energy
to the muscles and they're able to
utilize more energy
so that's long duration so we've got
muscular endurance and we've got long
duration endurance
and then there are two kinds in between
that
in recent years have gotten a lot of
attention and excitement
but most people are not distinguishing
between these two kinds
of endurance and that's a shame because
in failing to distinguish between the
two kinds of what we call high intensity
training
sometimes called high intensity interval
most people perhaps you are not getting
nearly as much
physical and mental benefit out of high
intensity training as you could
so i want to talk about the two kinds of
high intensity interval training
and what each of them does for your
brain and body and
what sorts of adaptations they cause
because in doing that
you can really start to build up
specific energy systems
in your brain and body in ways that are
best serve you
for your cognitive work and
for other sorts of things like strength
and speed or hypertrophy
or for running marathons for that matter
so there are two kinds of high intensity
training for endurance sometimes called
high intensity interval training
one is anaerobic so-called anaerobic
endurance so no oxygen and the other is
aerobic
endurance both of which qualify as hiit
high intensity interval training so
let's talk about anaerobic endurance
first anaerobic endurance
from a protocol perspective is going to
be
3 to 12 sets okay
and these repetitions and i'll talk
about what the repetitions
are are going to be performed at
whatever speed
allows you to complete the work in good
safe
form okay so it could be fast could be
slow as
the work continues your repetitions may
slow down or it may
speed up chances are it's going to slow
down so what does this
work what do these sets look like
remember long slow distance is one
set muscular endurance is three to five
sets
high intensity anaerobic endurance is
going to be somewhere between three
and 12 sets and it's going to have a
ratio
of work to rest of anywhere from
three to one to one to five
okay so what would a three to one
ratio set look like well it's going to
be 30 seconds
of hard pedaling on the bike for
instance or running
or on the rower these are just examples
it could be in the pool
swimming it could be any number of
things or air squats or you know or
weighted squats if you will provided you
can manage that
30 seconds on 10 seconds off that's a
very brief
rest so three to one is just a good
example would be 30 seconds on 10
seconds off
the opposite extreme on that ratio be
one to five
so 20 seconds on 100 seconds off so you
do the work for
20 seconds then you rest 100 seconds now
what's the difference what should you do
three to one ratio so 30 seconds on 10
seconds off
or should you do one to five 20 seconds
on to 100 seconds off
well that will depend on whether or not
the quality of the movement
is important to you so let's just take a
look at the three to one ratio so in the
three to one ratio
if you're going to do 30 seconds of hard
pedaling on a bike followed by 10
seconds so maybe one of these what they
call assault bikes
and then you stop for 10 seconds and
then repeat chances are you will be able
to do
one two three four
maybe even as many as 12 sets if you're
really in good condition
that you'll be able to do all those
because pedaling on the bike doesn't
require a ton of skill
and if you do it incorrectly if your
elbow flares out a little bit or
something it's very unlikely that you'll
get injured unless it's really extreme
okay but the same movement done for
instance with kettlebells
so 30 seconds on 10 seconds off
the first set will probably be in good
form the second one will be in pretty
good form but let's say you're getting
to the fifth and sixth set and you're
going 30 seconds on 10 seconds off
chances are the quality of your
repetitions will degrade significantly
and you increase the probability that
you're going to get
injured or that you're going to damage
yourself in some way or that you can't
complete the movement
or that some smaller muscles like your
grip muscles might give out
okay so the quality of repetitions is
going to drop considerably
with the three to one approach if you're
just doing it for effort and we'll talk
about what this builds in your system in
a moment
that's fine but for most people
if quality of form is important so maybe
this
is uh using weights maybe you're doing
squats you're going to do 20 seconds on
and 100 seconds of rest
maybe it's even a barbell loaded squat
maybe you're doing kettlebells
maybe you've got some other resistance
there that's allowing you to do this
what you'll find is that the longer rest
even though it's 20 seconds of intense
effort followed by a longer rest of
about 100 seconds will allow you to
perform more
quality repetitions safely over time
so what does building anaerobic
endurance
look like and then i'll tell you what
it's actually good for
in the true practical sense what
anaerobic endurance
exercise generally looks like is that if
you decide to do this for the first week
you might do this
two or three times a week maybe even
just once a week depending on the other
things you're doing we'll talk about
programming at the end
and you would generate just three sets
so it might be
three sets of 20 seconds of hard effort
followed by
100 seconds rest then you repeat 20
seconds of hard effort 100 seconds rest
20 seconds whatever hard
100 seconds rest you might do that twice
a week
and then each week you're adding one or
two sets
okay in doing that you will build up
what we call anaerobic endurance
what is anaerobic endurance well let's
ask why
we fail anaerobic endurance is going to
be
taking your system into greater than
100 percent of your vo2 max it's going
to be taking your heart rate up
very high and it's going to
maximize your oxygen utilization systems
that is going to have effects that
are going to lead to fatigue at some
point in the workout and that fatigue
will trigger an adaptation
so let's ask what adaptation it's
triggering
well it's triggering both
mitochondrial respiration the ability of
your mitochondria to generate
more energy by using more oxygen because
you're bringing so
you're maxing out literally you're
getting above your vo2 max
you're hitting that threshold of how
much oxygen you can use in your system
one of the adaptations will be that your
mitochondria will shift
such that they can use more oxygen
and you're going to also increase the
capillary beds but not as much as you're
going to be able
to increase the amount of neuron
engagement of muscle
so normally when we start to hit fatigue
when we're exhausted
when we're breathing really hard because
the systems of the body are linked and
we there's a mental component to this as
well
a kind of motivational component after
that third or fourth or sixth set of
you know 20 seconds on 100 seconds off
or if you're at the other extreme 30
seconds on and 10 seconds off
there's going to be a component of you
want to stop
and by pushing through and repeating
another set safely of course
what you're doing is you are training
the neurons to be able to
access more energy literally convert
that into atp
and for the muscles therefore to access
more energy and atp
and the adaptation is in the
mitochondria's ability to use oxygen
and this has tremendous carryover
effects for other types of exercise
so while i know and appreciate that
people are using high intensity interval
training of this kind or similar
in order to just like burn fat you know
do their workouts quote unquote
it's very useful for building a capacity
to engage in short bouts of effort
repeatedly
to really lock in i don't want to use
the word focus because it's not strictly
mental focus but to be able to
to generate short bouts of very intense
work
this can be beneficial in competitive
sports or team sports where there's a
sprinting component where the field
opens up and you need to dribble the
ball down the field for instance and
shoot on goal
or where you're playing tennis and it's
a long rally and then all of a sudden
somebody really starts you know putting
you back on your heels and you have to
really
make the maximum amount of effort to run
to the net and to get the ball across
that things of that sort
okay there are a variety of places where
there's carryover from this type of
training
but it does support endurance it's about
muscle endurance it's about these
muscles
ability to generate a lot of force in
the short term
but repeatedly okay so that's the way to
conceptualize this
and it is different than maximum power
even though it feels like maximum effort
it is not the same as building power and
speed into muscles those are distinctly
different
protocols so the key elements again
are that you're bringing your breathing
and your oxygen utilization
way up above your max it's not quite
hitting failure
but you're really pushing the system to
the point where
you are not ready to do another set and
yet you begin another set you're not
necessarily psychologically ready
i'll talk more about some of the
adaptations that this causes in terms of
stroke volume
in a few minutes when we talk about how
it is that
work of this sort can increase our
heart's ability to deliver blood and
oxygen to our lungs and other tissues
i'm going to get very specific about how
to breathe during these different types
of protocols
and what's happening at the level of the
heart but i want to make sure i touch on
the fourth protocol
which is high intensity aerobic
conditioning
so hit has these two forms anaerobic and
aerobic
and you just heard about anaerobic
high-intensity aerobic conditioning
also involves about three to twelve sets
starting off of course with fewer sets
as you're getting into this training and
then extending into
more sets as one parameter you could
expand
has again the same ratio of three to one
so 30 seconds on 10 seconds off or one
to five
20 seconds on 100 seconds off or a very
powerful tool
for building up aerobic conditioning is
a one-to-one ratio
a one-to-one ratio is powerful for
building
on average most of the energy systems
involving remember we have these nerve
muscle
blood heart and lungs a one to a one to
one ratio might be
you run a mile and however long that
takes let's say it takes you six minutes
or seven minutes then you rest for an
equivalent amount of time
then you repeat it and then you rest for
an equivalent amount of time so you
might run
first mile is let's say seven minutes
then you rest for seven minutes then you
run a mile again and it might take
eight minutes and you rest for eight
minutes and you continue that for a
total of
four miles of work for four miles of
running work
i should say or seven miles of work you
can build this up
many people find that using this type of
training
allows them to do things like go run
half marathons in marathons even though
prior to the race date they've never
actually run a half marathon or marathon
now that might seem incredible it's like
how could it be
that running a mile on and then and then
resting for running a mile and then
resting for an equivalent amount of time
running them out resting for equivalent
amount of time
for seven miles allows you to run
continuously for 13 miles
or for 26 miles well i'm not
discouraging people from
ever doing the long duration endurance i
think that is very important
but it's because it builds up so many of
these
energy utilization systems it really
teaches you to
engage excuse me the nerve to muscle
firing
it improves atp and mitochondrial
function in muscle
it allows the blood to deliver more
oxygen
to the muscle and to your brain and i'll
explain
how that is and it allows your heart to
deliver
more oxygen overall and it builds a
tremendous
lung capacity and we will talk about
exactly how to breathe and how to build
lung capacity
both for sake of warming up and for
performance so what would this look like
and when should you do this
um well it's really a question
for these workouts of asking how much
work can one do
in 8 to 12 minutes right and then rest
and then repeat
how much work can you do for eight to
twelve minutes then rest and then repeat
and how
many times should you do this well this
is the sort of thing it's pretty intense
and so you would probably only want to
do this two
maybe three times a week if you're not
doing many other things i will talk
about how this program can be
moved in with other forms of training
but i'll just give you a little hint now
it's very clear and it's described in
the review article
referred to and we will link another
article as well
that concurrent training doing strength
training and the endurance training of
any of the four cons that i'm describing
today
can be done you can program those in the
same week but you want to get
four and ideally six or even better
24 hours between these workouts because
it is very hard for instance to do a
one-to-one
mile repeats like run a mile rest for
equivalent time run a mile rest for
equivalent time
to do that two or three times a week and
also do weight training before or do a
long run
afterwards that would quickly lead to
breakdown for most people unless you
have very
very good energy utilization systems
you're a really kind of
advanced or elite athlete and or
dare i say you're using tools to enhance
your performance at the level of blood
or hormones and i'm actually going to
talk about those at the end
and why they work so we have four kinds
of endurance muscular endurance
we have long duration endurance we have
high intensity interval training of two
kinds anaerobic
and aerobic and this last type the
aerobic
one works best it seems if you kind of
do this one-to-one ratio so how would
you use these and what are they actually
doing
let's talk about the heart and the lungs
and oxygen
because that's something that we can all
benefit from understanding
and it will become very clear in that
discussion why this type of training is
very useful
even for non-athletes in order to
improve oxygenation and
energy utilization of the brain and the
heart
the brain and the heart are probably the
two most important systems that you need
to take care of in your life
yes your musculature needs to be
maintained if you want to build it
that's up to you
but you should try and maintain your
musculature but maintaining or enhancing
brain function and cardiovascular
function it's absolutely clear our key
for health and longevity in the short
and long term and the sorts of training
i talked about today
has been shown again and again and again
to be very useful
for enhancing the strength of the mind
yes i'll talk about that as well as the
health of the brain
and the body so let's talk about the
sorts of adaptations that are happening
in your brain and body that are so
beneficial
in these different forms of training if
you are breathing hard and your heart is
beating hard so this would be
certainly in the high intensity
anaerobic
and aerobic conditioning because you're
getting up near your vo2 max
in high intensity aerobic conditioning
and you're exceeding your
vo2 max in high intensity anaerobic
conditioning what's going to happen is
as of course your heart beats faster
your blood is going to be circulating
faster in principle
oxygen utilization in muscles is going
to go up
and over time not long very quickly what
will happen
when those capillary beds start to
expand we talked about that
but in addition because of
the amount of blood that's being
returned to the heart when you engage in
these really intense bouts of effort
repeatedly the amount of blood being
returned to the heart
actually causes an eccentric loading
of one of the muscular walls of the
heart
so your heart is muscle it's cardiac
muscle we have skeletal muscle attached
to our bones and we have cardiac muscle
which is our heart
when more blood is being returned to the
heart because of the additional work
that your muscles and nerves are doing
it actually has the effect of creating
an eccentric loading a kind of
pushing of the wall the left
i realize i'm not using the strict
anatomy here but i don't want to get
into
all the features of the structural
features of the heart
but the left ventricle essentially
getting slammed back and then having to
push back
in a kind of eccentric loading of the
cardiac muscle and
the muscle thickens but not because the
heart thickens overall
it's actually a strengthening of the
cardiac muscle in a way that increases
what we call
stroke volume meaning as more blood is
returned to the heart
there's an adaptation where the heart
muscle actually gets stronger
and therefore can pump more blood per
stroke per beat
and as it does that it delivers
because blood cont contains glucose and
oxygen and other things it delivers
more fuel to your muscles which allows
you to do yet more work
per unit time okay so when we hear that
oh you know
uh so-and-so has a or maybe you have a
nice low
heart rate that you know maybe you're
one of these really extreme folks like
30 or 40 beats per minute although most
people are sitting at 50 60 70 80 that's
your resting heart
rate if you exercise regularly and you
do long duration
aerobic work your heart rate will
start to go down your resting heart rate
it will increase the stroke volume of
your heart
if you do this high intensity type
training where your heart is beating
very hard so maybe the one-to-one ratio
mile run repeats that i described a
minute ago so you do that twice a week
for three or four and i said it could go
all the way up to 12
sets which is a lot i don't recommend
people start there pretty soon
the stroke volume of your heart will
really increase and as a consequence you
can deliver
more fuel to your muscles and to your
brain
and you will notice that you can do more
work
meaning you can do the same work you
were doing a few days or weeks ago with
relative ease your cognitive functioning
will improve this has been shown again
and again
because there's an increase in
vasculature literally capillary beds
within the brain the hippocampus
areas that support memory but also areas
of the brain that support
respiration that support focus that
support effort
this isn't often discussed but the
ability to deliver more blood
and therefore more glucose remember
neurons run on glucose and oxygen to the
brain
is a big feature of why exercise of the
kind i'm describing
helps with brain function now
weight training does have some positive
effects on brain function
also when i say weight training i'm
really i should be more specific i
really am referring to
strength and hypertrophy training
strengthen hypertrophy training
especially if it's of the sort where you
get into the burn as we talked about
last episode and you start generating
lactate as a hormonal signal
that can benefit your brain etc it can
have positive effects on the brain
and frankly there haven't been as many
studies of resistance training
strength and hypertrophy training on
brain function mainly because
most of those experiments are done in
mice or primates
non-human primates i should say and um
it's hard to get mice to do resistance
training okay it's hard to get humans to
do resistance training
it's definitely hard to get mice to do
resistance training there are ways to do
it but it's hard to get them to do say
you know
three sets of eight on the deadlift and
then do some curls and then do some chin
ups and this kind of thing
okay it's pretty easy to get a mouse to
run on a treadmill
and you can set the tension on that
treadmill to
make it so that it's easier or harder
for the mouse to turn that wheel
so that's one of the reasons however
it's
very clear and you should now understand
intuitively why
the kind of standard strength and
hypertrophy type workouts are not going
to
activate the blood oxygenation and the
stroke volume increases for the heart
that the sorts of training i'm talking
about today will it just doesn't have
the same positive
effects now that isn't to say that if
you just weight train that you'll be
dumb or that you'll lose
your your memory over time you might but
it is to say that endurance work in
particular
the high intensity and long duration
work that i've talked about today the
two high intensity protocols and the
long duration
work has been shown again and again and
again to have positive effects on brain
function
not through the addition of new neurons
sorry to break break it to you but
that's not a major event
in the exercised or non-exercised human
brain
for reasons we can talk about in a
future episode but it
still has many positive effects through
the delivery of things like igf-1 but
also just through plane
oxygenation of the brain and
the way it promotes the development of
microvasculature to devel
to excuse me to deliver neurons more
nutrients
if neurons don't get oxygen and glucose
they do die
unless there's another fuel source like
ketones which can replace the glucose
if you don't give oxygen to neurons if
you don't deliver enough to them
you get what's called ischemia you get
little microstrokes so
the type of exercise i'm talking about
today in generating
intense heart rate increases provided
that's safe for you to do
breathing hard that's going to deliver
oxygen and blood increased stroke volume
of the heart and is going to improve
brain function that's been supported by
many many
quality peer-reviewed studies so that's
one form of positive adaptation
i also talked about just sort of
performance adaptations how doing high
intensity aerobic conditioning
of the you know mild repeats type
training can actually improve your
ability to do long bouts of intense work
it also seems like it dovetails or is
compatible with
resistance training that's aimed towards
strength and hypertrophy now
in full disclosure the data seem to
indicate that if people
just weight train or train for strength
so three reps
um rest five minutes three reps of heavy
weights etc yeah you'll get
much stronger than you would if you're
doing things like you know five
repetitions up to 12 or 12 to 25 reps
and you're
you know and you're going out for long
jogs there's always going to be a
compromise in adaptations unfortunately
it does seem like you can do concurrent
training as i mentioned before if you
allow anywhere from four to six or
ideally 24 hours between workouts
as i mentioned in the previous episode
if you want to know if you are recovered
from a workout a great way to do that is
to apply the carbon dioxide tolerance
test
which is four breaths in and out inhale
exhale inhale exhale inhale exhale
inhale exhale then a big inhale
and then a slow controlled exhale if
that slow controlled exhale
is 60 seconds or longer it means that
your parasympathetic your calming
nervous system
is under your control and it's likely i
should say likely that systemically your
whole nervous system has recovered from
whatever it is that you've been doing
and experiencing in life including
work and relationships if not you might
want to take a rest day dare i say
or costello's on is what he's 10 now i
think he's on his
12 000th rest day um most people need
i should say one to two full rest days
per week i know there are people gonna
say that's ridiculous
and okay maybe you have uh amazing
recovery abilities
it also depends on training intensity
many people benefit from having one or
two full rest days per week
at least one some people don't need to
but
if you are not able to extend that
exhale on the carbon dioxide tolerance
test past
60 seconds or so 45 seconds 60 seconds
chances are your so-called sympathetic
nervous system your stress system is
chronically elevated and you're not
really putting the brake
on that system enough and that's a
subconscious thing there are ways that
you can
accelerate recovery but i would
encourage you to listen to the previous
episode it's time stamped for how to
assess recovery
so how often to program these things
will depend on the other things you're
doing
i think it's perfectly reasonable to do
this type of training
with other types of training and i'll
talk about a variety of combinations of
those toward the
end of the episode i do want to talk
about how to deliver
more energy and oxygen these are tools
that are extremely useful
i believe and that are grounded in
physiology
the three things i'd like to talk about
are how to breathe
what to do immediately after training
and
hydration and i promise i will get back
into programming and sort of protocols
but i these are vitally important to
your ability to perform
endurance work in particular and they're
grounded in how
neurons and blood and oxygen and your
heart work together so let's first talk
about
breathing or respiration we breathe
a couple of different ways but let's
just remind ourselves why we breathe we
breathe to bring
oxygen into our system and we breathe to
get rid of carbon dioxide and
we need both oxygen and carbon dioxide
in order
to utilize fuel and for our brain and
body to work it's not that oxygen is
good and carbon dioxide is bad
they have to be present in the
appropriate ratios
so one thing that is very clear is our
ability to deliver
oxygen to working muscles and to our
brain
is going to be important for our ability
to generate
muscular effort especially of the kind
of was talking about today but also
weight training and other forms of skill
based effort etc
and our ability to think if you're
holding your breath for too long if
you're breathing too much
if you're what they call over breathing
or under breathing if you're shallow
breathing if you're mouth breathing
these are all
things that can really impede mental and
physical performance so
let's make it really simple and then i
promise to do a future episode
all about respiration there are two main
sources
of air for your body and it's air coming
in through your nose and air coming in
through your mouth
in general nasal breathing is better
it scrubs the air of bacteria and
viruses
you have a microbiome in your nose that
benefits
there are a number of reasons it's also
just a more efficient system believe it
or not even though it feels like you can
gulp more air with your mouth
getting good at nasal breathing is
useful
a gear system of the type that brian
mckenzie and colleagues have developed i
think is a good way to conceptualize
this if you're doing long duration work
try and do it all nasal breathing if you
have deviated septum it's probably
because you don't nasal breathe enough
mouth breathing is something that you
know many people suffer from
it you're more prone to infections it's
not as in
efficient etc there is a place for mouth
breathing however
it's usually if you need to do a strong
exhale
often times you can discard more volume
through the mouth
unless you're very trained at nasal
breathing so if you're doing high
intensity training a good way to
conceptualize this is to
exhale on the max effort and then to
inhale
on the less intense part so that might
be as you're generating the movement
you know you in the concentric part of
the movement you exhale
right just like on a bat swing or
something like that or
you know fighters and martial artists do
this differently depending on how they
were trained and the different purposes
but the kind of like
or the kind of exhaling um during the
effort and then inhaling
on the portion of the repetition that is
not the
highest effort portion usually that's
the eccentric phase
of anything involving weights or rowing
and things of that sort
so nasal breathing is great but as you
increase the intensity of your endurance
work you will need to incorporate the
mouth so a gear system would look
something like first gear would be just
nasal breathing
or second gear would also be just nasal
breathing but with more effort
third gear again power speed endurance
has a lot more about this you can go to
their website
i think it's a very intelligent way to
conceptualize this
um as you go into more max effort then
you're going to you know third and
fourth and fifth gear and at some point
you're not thinking about nose or mouth
you're just trying to hang on for dear
life and complete the work safely
and that means breathe through uh
whatever
uh orifice uh works for you so
that's one aspect nose versus mouth the
other
aspect is whether or not you're using
your ribs the intercostal muscles are
these muscles that the bruce lee had
these
you know remarkable intercostal muscles
that allow you to lift the rib cage or
the diaphragm which is a skeletal muscle
that sits below the lungs just to remind
you when you inhale the diaphragm moves
down when you exhale
the diaphragm moves up
okay here's something that most people
don't do
and would benefit tremendously from and
i can say this because andy galpin's lab
has done
work on this exploring how warming up
the intercostals and the nerve to
diaphragm pathways before
any kind of endurance work or in the
first few minutes of endurance work
can allow you to breathe more deeply and
to deliver more oxygen to the blood
and excuse me end to the muscles and to
be able to do
more work more efficiently so what that
involves is
sometimes sitting sometimes standing and
just really concentrating on
two things we always hear about how we
should diaphragmatic breathe and that
means our belly moves out when we
inhale so our our stomach expands but
also expanding the intercostals which
means actually raising the ribs chest
breathing we're all told that you know
in yoga class don't breathe with your
chest this
but actually that is is warming up the
intercostal muscles
so this is also a great way to generate
adrenaline if you do it
a little bit intensely so let's say
you're feeling un motivated to train
i don't particularly like doing
endurance training until i'm actually
doing it
um so i i use and benefit from having a
practice where i'll just sit there and
for about three minutes i'll just
breathe very deeply trying to raise my
chest as much as i can
for maybe a minute and then expanding my
contracting my diaphragm and expanding
my stomach outward when i inhale
by the end of that you're actually
delivering more oxygen to your system
um my lab has looked at this in a
totally different context andy's lab has
looked at it in the context
of physical performance so warming up
the breathing muscles
should make sense given that you now
know that muscles and neurons need
glucose and they need oxygen
in order to function and so that's a
great warm-up you can also do this while
walking
or while getting on the bike and
starting to pedal really starting to
think about
warming up the breathing system and then
you can decide if you want to do pure
nasal or a combination of nasal and
mouth breathing
and so on so that's something that we
don't often hear about the other one
the other tool rather that i've talked
about in a previous episode i'll just
mention again is some people
when they do endurance type work they
get a stitch in their side they feel
like they've got a side
cramp very rarely is it actually a
skeletal muscular cramp it's
oftentimes it's a referenced pain of the
phrenic nerve
that innervates the liver so the phrenic
nerve is responsible for the
movement of the diaphragm it is a very
important system but it has a number of
what we call collateral so it branches
to other organs
runs over other organs sometimes when
we're breathing
shallow and we are in physical motion
and we're engaging in physical effort
we'll feel that side stitch we think oh
i've got a cramp or maybe i'm dehydrated
or maybe i need to run with my hands
over my head my head excuse me
typically you can relieve that side
cramp which isn't a cramp at all that
side stitch
by doing the double inhale exhale really
breathing deeply
and then sneaking a little bit more air
in
that's a double kind of firing or what
we call
volley of action potential sent from the
phrenic nerve to
the diaphragm which will also activate
that collateral that
branch literally of the nerve that
innervates the liver and then
when you exhale you offload a bunch of
carbon dioxide but if you repeat that a
few times
often in fact for me every time but
often what will happen is that side
stitch will just naturally disappear
just means you're not breathing properly
your
the phrenic nerve is is firing in a way
that's kind of
aggravating that referenced pain there's
nothing kind of voodoo or mysterious
about this it just has to do with the
way that the different nerves
uh travel in the body so as you set out
on your run or maybe you're going to do
some
muscular endurance work or high
intensity work
warming up the intercostals warming up
the diaphragm is is
good and there there are exercises there
is work that you can do to strengthen
the intercostals
and to strengthen the diaphragm during
bouts of this kind of effort
and i would say that one of the ways
that you can do that best
is by really focusing on getting the
maximum
diaphragmatic expansion and chest
lifting what we're all told now not to
do don't you know don't chest breathe
belly breathe the intercostals are there
for a reason
and they are perfectly good at filling
your lungs they work best when they
collaborate with your diaphragm
but when you're starting to fatigue to
start to really inhale
deeply and try and really expand those
to deliver more oxygen
to your system while we're talking about
delivering more oxygen to your system
i want to share with you a useful tool
that will now make total sense
mechanistically why it works
which is often times when we are on
a long run or in long duration bouts of
effort
we will hit the so-called wall right we
will bonk i think they used to call it
or maybe do they still call it that
costello
he's asleep we bonk we just we think no
we can't continue it's a curious thing
as to whether or not that's
neural or whether or not it's fuel-based
there's certainly going to be a
psychological or motivational component
but one way that you can reveal this
kind of extra gear the capacity to push
on is by understanding the way that
different muscle fibers use energy
differently remember the fast twitch
phosphor creatine system and the slow
twitch system that relies mainly on
lipids and glucose
okay well even if you don't remember all
that if you've been running steadily for
a long time and you're starting to
fatigue and you feel like it's time to
quit
you may have not tapped into an
alternative fuel source
one thing that you can do is you can
actually increase your speed this is
also true
of work where you're doing repetitions
with kettlebells or something you can
start to increase your speed so
run faster pedal faster row faster swim
faster
not all out sprint but in doing that
you're shifting the muscles
and the nerves over towards utilizing a
separate fuel source or a distinct fuel
source
maybe the phosphocreatine system if it's
a quick bout of intense
acceleration or maybe it's a combination
of
lipids and carbohydrates in your system
that weren't available to you
prior now of course if you completely
deplete your liver glycogen you
completely deplete
everything you're only going to be
running on stored fuel and fats and
and eventually you'll start metabolizing
protein muscles
themselves but this is a kind of a
a unique way to realize that oh you
weren't
uh you weren't out of energy at all you
were just over relying on
one fuel source and this is the reason
why especially elite athletes are
starting to
both rely on carbohydrates so they're
doing the whole carb depletion then carb
loading thing they're loading up their
liver and their muscles with plenty of
glycogen by eating pastas and rice and
stuff before races but they are also
ingesting ketones
during races during long ballots of
effort because
ketones can be a quick form of energy
there's no reason why you can't use
ketones if they are
taken exogenous ketones and carbohydrate
and in combination remember the body
is accustomed to using multiple fuel
sources fatty acids carbohydrates
all these things it's only in the you
know kind of internet age that we
think in terms of oh well you're either
keto or you're burning sugar
or you're you know fat adapted or you're
fat fasting or fast fasting or
fat fatting costello woke up when i said
fat fatting i'm not talking about you
costello so the the point is that your
body is used to using multiple fuel
sources so if you're kind of hitting
that wall
sometimes accelerating can actually
allow you to tap into a new fuel source
or combination of fuel sources just
based on the way that muscles use
fuel so that's another tool the other
thing that's really important to think
about in terms of endurance type work
is hydration and i think hydration is
important for all forms of physical work
and exercise not just endurance the deal
with hydration
is that we've been taught about
hydration all wrong but let's remember
what neurons
work on what what do they use in order
to fire well
they certainly need water right we need
water in our system i should say but
they remember they use electrolyte
sodium and potassium to generate
those action potentials to actually get
neurons to contract to be able
excuse me muscles to contract and for
our brain to function and to be able to
think
typically typically we're going to lose
anywhere from
one to five pounds of water per hour of
exercise and that's going to vary
tremendously it's going to vary on
weather it's going to vary on intensity
probably more like five pounds
if it's hot day and you're exercising
very intensely
so about one to five pounds per hour
now you know how much you weigh so
if you think about your weight in pounds
once you lose about one to four percent
of your body weight
in water you're going to experience
about a 20 to 30 percent reduction
in work capacity in your ability to
generate
effort of any kind strength endurance
etc you are also going to experience a
significant
drop in your ability to think and
perform mental operations
so hydration is key now many people have
been told well
if you urinate and your urine is clear
well then
you're hydrated enough sometimes that's
true sometimes that's not true
also and this isn't a topic i enjoy um
discussing but
urine is a biological phenomenon it's
actually filtered blood
um every once in a while if there's a
kid and it's a family friend i'll say
did you know that your pee is
actually filtered blood and they usually
kind of go wide-eyed but then they go oh
that's kind of cool like kids have this
natural curiosity about
blood and pee and stuff that's not
contaminated by our
preconceived notions of those things
being gross
because urine being filtered blood can
give you some indication as to
whether or not you're hydrated enough or
not and
in order to really assess that it's not
going to be sufficient to
urinate into another volume of water and
assess whether or not your urine is very
dark or very light it actually requires
urinating into a small volume and saying
well is it darker or lighter than before
it's not something you really want to do
most places
um the etiquette of most gyms and
environments is not suitable for that
but one of the things that you can just
do is you can figure well i'm going to
lose one to five pounds of water per
hour you can show up to exercise
reasonably hydrated with electrolytes so
potassium sodium and magnesium are
really key
yes it's true you can die from drinking
too much water in particular because it
forces you
if you drink too much water you'll
excrete too many electrolytes and your
brain will shut off
you'll actually your heart will stop
functioning properly so you don't want
to over consume water to the extreme
either
but there are a number of equations that
go into figuring out how much water you
need
based on how intense you're training etc
body size etc
just remember you burn you lose excuse
me about one to five pounds of
of water per hour depending on how hot
it is and how intensely you're
exercising
once your body weight drops by one to
four percent so you can just
figure well if you lose five pounds per
hour you exercise for two hours
let's say you're about 200 pounds that's
about 10 okay
well you want to replace that before you
very quickly or not
you want to replace that all along
before you start experiencing this
massive 20-30
reduction in work capacity of muscles in
the brain a simple formula what i call
the galpin
equation hereafter referred to as the
galpin
equation is a formula that gets you
close to the exact amount that you would
want
that dr andy galpin came up with which
is your body weight
in pounds divided by the number 30
and that is how many ounces you should
drink for every 15
minutes of exercise so once again the
galloping equation
your body weight in pounds divided by 30
that's the amount of of fluid
to drink in ounces right every 15
minutes of exercise now if you are
sweating a lot you may need more
okay if you're already very well
hydrated you may need
less but that's a good rule of thumb to
begin
and to start to understand the
relationship between hydration
and performance there is a phenomenon
in which gastric emptying
the ability to move stuff out of your
gut including water
and electrolytes out of your gut and
into the bloodstream and for delivery to
the tissues of your body for effort
is hindered when you get above 70 of
your vo2 max in other words when you're
doing high intensity training
sometimes people experience that
ingesting water
during intense training is difficult it
is something that can be
actually trained up it's a matter of
learning to kind of
relax the your abdominal muscles
and there's some other aspects of
adaptation that will allow you to drink
during higher intensity work
as galpin says don't try and
ingest fluids when you're working out or
competing at higher than 70 of vo2 max
if you've never done it before you want
to train up this capacity
people can learn how to consume fluids
during a race or consume fluids
during bouts of exercise that are very
intense
and a lot of people don't want to do
that because they don't want to have to
stop to urinate etc
but given the crucial role of hydration
for muscular performance and for brain
performance
it seems that if you're going to be
doing a lot of high intensity interval
training
of the various kinds we talked about
today or high intensity training of any
kind
that hydration is key and learning or in
other words getting your system to adapt
to ingesting fluids
in the middle of these workouts is
something that seems beneficial at least
to me
in terms of the trade-off between being
dehydrated
and the somewhat discomfort of maybe
drinking some fluids so you sip small
amounts of fluid initially and then
you're able to take bigger and bigger
gulps as time goes on and pretty soon um
you're able to drink
mid-set or be excuse me not mid-set
please don't do that between sets and
your workout or while you're still
breathing hard after a mile repeat or
something
of that sort without much disruption or
any at all to your performance
last episode we talked about how to
assess recovery
and things that you might want to do to
improve recovery how exposure to ice
baths and cold showers can reduce
inflammation which can be great for
recovery
but can inhibit some of the adaptations
for strength and hypertrophy because
inflammation isn't good or bad
inflammation isn't like
a nice person or a mean person it's both
it's
a great thing for stimulating
adaptations but you don't want it around
too long and so we suggested that you
not do ice baths within
probably six hours of any training where
the goal was hyper
hypertrophy or strength training there
is some evidence that getting yourself
into an ice bath or cold shower
after endurance training can actually
improve
the mitochondrial uh aspects of
endurance exercise that you can get
improvements in mitochondrial density
and you can get improvements in
mitochondrial respiration by doing that
afterwards and that it can facilitate
recovery
that's still a bit of a controversial
area i do think that what i mentioned
earlier that waiting at least six hours
and probably more like 24 hours between
workouts
is a good idea that getting at least one
full day of rest each week for some
people that'll be two
i have to say i'm one of these people
that after two days of absolutely no
exercise
i do perform better consistently across
all aspects of physical performance and
mentally
i feel better as well even though i
loathe to take those days off
unless i'm really exhausted it does seem
to help my training some people can
train seven days a week and they're fine
i think it just is there's a lot of
individual variation
you want to work on sleep and maximizing
sleep for recovery nutrition of course
as well
i talked about sleep in the first four
episodes of the podcast so if you have
trouble with sleep
definitely check out those episodes it's
very clear
and a number of sports teams um even
some folks that i work with
uh and andy galpin and others are
starting to incorporate a what's called
a parasympathetic down regulation after
training of any kind as a way to
accelerate recovery and enable you to do
more work
in other words get back to work out
sooner what is parasympathetic down
regulation it means finishing your
your training and instead of just
hopping on the phone or hopping into
your car and
and um heading off to take five minutes
minimum
maybe ideally more like 10 or 20 but for
sake of time
five minutes minimum and doing just some
slow pure nasal
long exhale devoted breathing we're
lying down and just kind of zoning out
that it seems can accelerate recovery
and allow you to get
back into other types of work mental
work or physical work
more quickly which makes total sense
because remember your nervous system
and recovery and work is a local
phenomenon which muscles were you using
you know were you using your your glutes
your hams and your and your back or
where you're using your shoulders etc
but it's also a systemic thing
it's also about those neurons and the
locus ceruleas that are releasing
epinephrine you want to
quiet all that down after training you
want to really just zone out
think costello channel your inner
costillo and just
mellow out for five to 20 minutes and
then move into
the rest of your day five minutes should
be manageable even if it's just sitting
in the car with your eyes closed doing
that down regulation breathing
i think you'll see big benefits in terms
of allowing yourself to come back
sooner do more work over time
and just perform and feel better
generally as well as be able to think
about other things besides the just how
much the previous workout kind of beat
you up
a couple more things i think are going
to be useful and i do want to just
pack these in because we are closing out
the month on physical performance
and that's about programming and about
pacing and the kind of mental aspects of
endurance
so let's start with pacing and mental
aspects of endurance
i learned from a friend and colleague
here at the podcast that who's very
active in triathlon and marathon and
other knows a lot about that whole world
and the competitive landscape there
that pacing and literally
physical pacers of a laser on the ground
or visualizing
or having a pace car or a pace runner in
front
is actually not allowed in many
competitions and
if those are present doesn't allow the
race times to qualify
as legitimate record-holding times and
that's very interesting to me because
what we know is that the visual system
has this capacity to switch back and
forth between what we call panoramic
vision where we're not really focused on
anything
things are just flowing past us or our
eyes are just kind of zoned out
so i can do this right now and you won't
be able to tell but i'm looking at the
corners of the room i see costillo down
there on the floor i see my
podcast team here and i can also see the
microphone i can see myself in this
environment that's panoramic vision
whereas if i draw my eyes to one
location like right there in the center
of the camera
it's what's called a virgin's eye
movement so i'm contracting my visual
window
the contraction of the visual window
when that's done
is the same thing that would happen if i
was tracking say a pace car or a pace
runner
or a laser on the ground the mirror
bringing our eyes together to
what we call a vergence point has the
impact
of triggering the activation of neural
circuits in the
thalamus things like zona and serta if
you really want to know what their names
are
of these brain areas as well as in the
brain stem that activate
the so-called alertness system things
like locus ceruleus whereas
panoramic vision tends to bring us into
states of relaxation
you can actually leverage this during
your runs let's say you're out for
a long run or you're swimming or you're
cycling this is probably easiest to
imagine
out of the water but you probably do in
the water as well if you
focus your attention on a landmark that
you're going to run to
you'll find that it's much easier than
if you don't actually have a set
milestone or landmark that you're going
to run to however if you were to
continue that repeatedly just going
milestone after milestone after
milestone
you would feel more mentally fatigued
and you would actually be able to
generate less work overall one thing
that
can be useful is focusing on a milestone
running to that milestone or biking
whatever it is the activity happens to
be and then dilating your field of view
to relax the system and then continuing
again so it's this kind of active
contraction or of the visual window and
then dilation of the visual window
contraction the visual window allows you
to generate more effort but there's a
cost to doing that because neurons
consume
energy and now you know how they do that
whereas dilation
allows you to essentially be more
efficient
right now pacing is not allowed or
having a pace or a visual
pacer because it does allow you to
access systems in the brain and body
that allow you to create more energy
more effort and so i find it interesting
that i think in a kind of subconscious
genius the
race officials and the the governing
bodies of these of these races
have said okay sure having a pacer there
or someone in front you can draft off of
them there's actually a kind of a
aerodynamic effect of having someone in
front of you that makes it easier
to run in the wake of their of their
airstream so to speak
same is true in cycling this is why the
cycling teams are so good at maneuvering
in packs in very
specific ways you can go faster with
less effort if you're drafting as it's
called behind somebody
but as well where you place your vision
will allow you to generate
more effort and so it's interesting that
they've taken out this kind of um
if you will performance enhancing tool i
imagine
and i have to imagine it's the
appropriate word here that
ra good runners good cyclists
have the ability to create a kind of
pacer in their mind's eye i have to
imagine that they're not just completely
allowing their attention to drift
although they do that when they want to
be in
highly efficient mode generating effort
without having to tax their mental
capacity and remember mental capacity
is neural energy and consumes glucose
energy that they could
devote to the functioning of their body
but that when needed
that they can focus their energy in and
actually kind of chase a mental pacer or
pick milestones so this is a mental game
that you can play
as well it's a little bit hard to do in
the context of weightlifting in the gym
it's more of a moving through space kind
of thing
but some people do this by counting reps
etc i think it's
especially suitable for endurance type
of exercise especially done outside one
of the reasons i hate running on a
treadmill is it just feels like
it's never ending and i i've never tried
one of these peloton things
i try and avoid looking at screens as
much as i possibly can
but if you try this next time you're out
for a run or a swim what you'll find is
that you have a capacity
to engage a system of higher energy
output when you focus your eyes on a
particular location but you want to use
that judiciously because
your goal of course is to become
efficient at moving through space over
time
and not taxing your brain and body to
the point where you
arrive at the end of that unless it's
race day just completely tapped out
so that's a kind of interesting aspect
of
running if you're a fan of running which
i am
and you get the chance to look at any of
the documentaries or docu-dramas made
about
excuse me about steve prefontaine it was
clear that he was mostly in a battle
with himself
but that he was also a highly
competitive individual and you'll see
this in some of his races
i do encourage you to look some of those
up on on youtube or see the docudramas
they're quite good
where he ran that the essentially was 12
laps on a track it's essentially the
five
it is the 5 000 meter race which
essentially three three miles
and he essentially tried to sprint the
whole thing which is ridiculous
actually knowing what you know today
you'll realize that steve prefontaine
basically was pulling from strength
speed power
muscular endurance long duration effort
high intensity aerobic anaerobic has
sort of tried to maximize
every fuel system and you'll see that in
the the races that he runs but that
when runners are nearing the final laps
the so-called bell lap of a race
they'll often look to one another to see
where somebody is obviously to assess
their progress and
and how close somebody is but when
somebody gets passed oftentimes you'll
see someone
access this mysterious kick this ability
to
tap into some additional gear that
allows them to run forward or
faster when they themselves actually
thought that they were maxed out
so someone could be running for the
finish line they're convinced they're
going to win they're going max
effort or at least they perceive max
ever someone passes them and all of a
sudden
max effort has changed because of that
visual target they are able to access
higher levels of speed and output and
effort and performance they don't always
catch up to that person and win
but having a target a milestone is
a powerful way that we can generate more
force and energy
in anything and the visual system is the
way that we bring those milestones
into our brain which then brings about
epinephrine which brings about
neural firing which allows us to access
whatever resources happen to be
available to us
so i find this fascinating because
people
often wonder like where does the kick
come from where is this
kind of gift of an additional gear where
is that deeper resource
and we often express it and talk about
it in kind of psychological terms like
heart
or willpower or that something kind of
got transplanted into us or descended
into us
and not to remove any of the spiritual
aspects of of sport or running or effort
of the human uh you know heart
but it's very clear that the nervous
system when it has a specific
visual target can generate the sorts of
intense effort
that it couldn't otherwise and it
sometimes even comes as a surprise to
the person generating the effort
i promised that i would talk about
programming meaning
when and how many times a week to do the
various workouts related to endurance
and how to
merge those with other types of exercise
that you might be doing for strength or
yoga
or other things that you might be doing
like work and other things unrelated to
exercise
since that's a vast space with
many different parameters and you all
have different lives and lifestyles and
backgrounds with fitness etc what i'm
going to do
is i'm going to put three different
levels if you will or
protocols that one could adopt in
a link on the show note so in the
caption
on youtube if you click on that link
you'll be able to see
three possible combinations of endurance
work
strength and hypertrophy work or
endurance work flexibility and
hypertrophy work
that are grounded in many of the major
publications that dr andy galpin and
colleagues and other people
have described including this review
that's also linked there
on concurrent training and how one can
use concurrent training
meaning training for endurance training
for strength training for hypertrophy
training for all these different things
without having to train constantly every
day twice a day etc
so if you are interested in taking the
protocols that you learned about
in this episode and in previous episodes
and combining those
we've placed them there for you as a
completely zero cost resource
please understand they are not holy
costello agrees they are not holy
there will be variation in terms of what
people can tolerate what they have time
for but i think they'll serve as a
useful guideline
in getting started or in continuing with
and expanding on existing
endurance work strength work hypertrophy
work
and so forth just really quickly we
didn't talk about supplements much today
in the previous episodes i talked about
the phosphocreatine system and
supplementing with creatine
talked about beta-alanine for kind of
moderate duration
work you know really the only things
that have been shown to really improve
endurance work across the four
varieties of endurance work i described
today
they have essentially two forms one are
stimulants so things like caffeine
will definitely improve endurance work
and power output
there's a little bit of evidence that
caffeine intake can actually inhibit the
function of the creatine system but it's
just one study but that's interesting
if you want to read that study you can
put caffeine into examine.com and it
will take you to that study
many people get sore after workouts in
particular workouts that involve
a lot of eccentric loading or workouts
that are very novel where they've kind
of pushed it instead of
moving gradually as i suggest into say
high intensity anaerobic endurance work
of three sets
of 20 seconds on 100 second rest maybe
you get overambitious and you do eight
sets in which case
you're extremely sore certain forms of
magnesium in particular magnesium malate
m-a-l-a-t-e have been shown to be useful
for removing or reducing the amount of
delayed onset muscle soreness
that form of magnesium is distinctly
different than the sorts of magnesium
that are good for getting us into sleep
things like magnesium 3 and 8 and by
glycinate
and then there's this whole thing about
beet
powder and beet juices and things that
increase nitric oxide
and allow for more vasodilation and
therefore delivery of blood to muscle
and neurons and other tissues for long
bouts of endurance work
some people like beet juice and the
related compounds that increase arginine
and vasodilation
some people don't some people don't feel
good
when they take those some people also
don't feel good when they take beta
alanine
because it can give them this feeling of
kind of like um itchy creepy
crawlies under the skin kind of the
niacin phenomenon the niacin flush
some people don't mind that or some
people don't experience that so when it
comes to supplementation there's a lot
of variety but
magnesium malate um has been shown to
reduce soreness so sometimes that's good
cold and hot contrast therapy for
soreness things of that sort
but in general we focused mainly today
on behavioral tools you'll notice that
all of the tools are accessible without
the need for
lots of equipment so i didn't say you
need a rower you need a kettlebell
though those will work
and i hope i was able to illustrate for
you that endurance isn't just one thing
it's not just the ability to go for
long bouts of exercise of different
kinds that there's also this mental
component because of the way that
neurons work
and also that there are these different
forms of endurance of muscular endurance
that where you're going to fail because
of the muscles
and muscle energy utilization and the
nerves that innervate those muscles
locally not because of a failure to
bring in oxygen or blood
whereas long-duration effort it's going
to be more about you know being below
your vo2 max and your ability to be
efficient for long bouts of more than 12
minutes
of exercise one set as they say of 12
minutes to
maybe several hours i should just
mention with long duration type work
you know you could even imagine raking
in the yard or mowing a lawn depending
on how big that lawn is i
used to had a job when i was a kid
mowing lawns and i'll tell you
we didn't have many neighbors with very
big lawns but um there are a few of them
felt huge
because they were really convoluted and
if you're pushing that mower and these
were the old-fashioned mowers not
electric mowers it's work that's also
of the sort that we call long-duration
endurance work high-intensity training
will tap into yet other fuel sources and
mechanisms as we learned today so
if you are enjoying this podcast and
you're
finding the information useful it would
be great if you would subscribe to the
youtube channel that really helps us
quite a lot and if you like you can
click click the notifications button on
youtube as well
that way you're sure to never miss an
episode we always release episodes on
monday but we also
sometimes release episodes in between
mondays
so please do subscribe to the youtube
channel please also give us feedback in
the comment section on the youtube
channel
that's where you can tell us about
topics that you want to hear
more about or if you have questions
about a given episode or content within
an episode
that's where you want to put that
feedback
if you're not already subscribing on
apple and spotify as well
please do that on apple you can give us
up to a five star review
we like to think that you would give us
a five star review but you can also
leave
comments on apple about the podcast more
generally and again
those are all zero cost ways that you
can really help support the podcast
we do have a patreon it is patreon.com
andrewhuberman at patreon.comhuberman
you can support the podcast at any level
that you like
please also check out our sponsors that
we mentioned at the beginning of the
podcast
i know ad reads are not the first thing
that people want to hear when they're
getting ready to consume scientific
information please understand
that the ads and the sponsors allow us
to bring the zero cost to consumer
information about science and science
related tools
to everybody so if you have the means
check out the
sponsors we only work with sponsors
whose products we really believe in
and that i actually use and really love
there's no obligation however
and we do talk about supplements from
time to time
again no obligation to use supplements
we also talk about behavioral tools
but if you are interested in supplements
please go to examine.com to evaluate
those supplements and their various
effects
if you're curious about that and we work
with
thorn t-h-o-r-n-e
thorn is a supplement manufacturer that
we believe has the highest levels of
stringency in terms of the quality of
the supplements
and they are very precise and very
stringent about the amounts of each of
those
compounds in the given supplements this
is a huge problem
elsewhere in the supplement industry
many brands don't include what they say
they include on the bottle it seems to
show up every time people
test different brands but thorn
continually tests out with the highest
levels of accuracy
and stringency if you want to see the
supplements that i take you can go to
thorne.com
the letter u slash huberman and if you
do that you can see all the supplements
that i take you can get 20
off any of those supplements as well if
you want to navigate into the main
thorn site and you see a supplement that
you're interested in
you'll also get 20 off any of those
supplements as well so that's thorne.com
the letter u huberman so we have both
cost free and other ways to help support
the podcast
if you know people that might be
interested in the podcast
and benefit from the information please
recommend it to them that really helps
us if you're on instagram check us out
at hubermann lab if you're on twitter
it's also huberman lab and please check
out our new website which is
hubermannlab.com
there you can find all the episodes of
all the podcasts batched according to
topic
in every format youtube apple and
spotify with links out to those it's
searchable
by keywords that you're interested in so
sleep or exercise weight training
strength
fat loss etc and you can subscribe to
our newsletter the neural network which
will allow you to get
zero cost updates about speaking events
about
any book releases or exciting things
that i'm reading that i think you would
enjoy reading as well
as well as protocols related to science
and some summary and important notes
from the podcast
and last but not least on behalf of
myself and costello
who's finally waking up for oh no he
went back to sleep
thank you for your interest in science